mais ce de caractère qui était
aussi les quand il me trouve génial dans
un film il faut qu'il sache que je
souffre de ce de
caractère la vie c'est ma passion mais
c'est bien vous ça c'est complètement
désespéré et en même temps ah mais oui
mais désespéré mais je peux pas arrêter
moi je peux pas arrêter ni de vivre ni
de faire et je ne peux pas clore ma vie
moi-même je l'aime trop donc je me
retrouve avec tout cette espèce de sac
cadeau et ainsi de suite et j'avance
malgré tout j'avance je dis j'ai 15 res
à faire debout antiubant peut-être mais
debout est-ce que Richard vous vous
retrouvez dans tout ce qui est dit par
vos amis par cette description de vous
d'ailleurs avec vos paradoxes ex que
c'estès dans la colère dans le désespoir
mais aussi dans la générosité ah oui
savez c'est des amis d'amour hein donc
s'ils le disent je le prends comme un
comme un cadeau somptueux tous se disent
que ce soit Gérard jugot Bernard oui
mais justement Gérard jugot qui parle si
bien de moi et je le remercie euh non
mais vraiment ça me touche beaucoup
qu'il parle comme ça de moi mais comment
ça se fait qu'on a pas refait de film
ensemble il en a fait plein qui étaient
super j'aurais bien aimé être dedans
voilà c'est tout ce que j'ai à dire donc
vous êtes blessé oui bien sûr ouais
ouais parce que j'ai donné plein plein
de coups de main dans ma vie quand même
quand je faisais quatre films par an
vous pensez bien qu'il y avait pas mal
de gens qui me traînaient au cul et qui
qui
ça veut dire vous savez acteur de cinéma
quand vous devenez voilà machin vous en
faites quatre parents vous avez des
Césars des choses comme ça vous avez été
bien récompensé oui oui oui c'est pour
ça d'ailleurs c'est étonnant quand un
métier récompense un mec comme moi et il
laisse complètement tomber pourquoi n'
fait plus appel à vous Richard à cause
de quoi c'est votre carère ou ce
de caractère mais ce de caractère
qui était aussi les quand il me trouve
génial dans un film il faut qu'il sache
que je souffre de ce de caractère
et c'est la souffrance en opposition à
ce de caractère qui fait que je
peux peut-être leur donner un tout petit
peu plus quoi que ce qu'ils attendit
vous avez d'ailleurs dit vous étiez
affamé d'amour assoifffé de femmes
affamé d'ailleurs tout court ce que vous
écriviez je crois la fin des années 60
lorsque vous avez rédigé ces deux pièces
orglub et les girafes qui sont
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui réédité aux
édition flamarion de magnifiques pièces
oui je suis affammé oui bien sûr et je
suis resté est-ce est-ce que vous l'êtes
toujours oui oui oui je sais pas ce que
ça veut dire très bien vous savez
excessif ou ou pas excessif je sais pas
très bien je crois que quand on est en
action on doit on doit prendre le
territoire quoi h euh qui ça soit un
territoire amical qu'on veut pousser
au-delà euh un territoire amoureux qu'on
veut pousser au-delà un territoire
créatif qu'on veut pousser c'est
jusqu'au bout tout le temps ah oui avec
vous Richard oui oui le temps oui tout
le temps dès le réveil d'ailleurs c'est
un peu plus en apparemment jusqu'au bout
tout dans la création dans la vie aussi
dans l'autodestruction oui mais j'ai pas
appelé ça l'autodestruction moi comment
vous appelez ça j'ai appelé ça ma
construction de passage par les drogues
l'alcool la conr jeis passé par là mais
je ne suis je ne bois plus je me drogue
plus c'est pas une rédemption non plus
c'est juste un acte lucide un respect
pour mon corps et ma pensée ça fait
maintenant anné ça s'est fort bien passé
immédiatement quoi mais vous avez écrit
d'ailleurs vous l'avez dit je crois que
vous l'avez écrit écrire est une
nécessité si je n'avais pas l'écriture
je serais mort depuis longtemps retombé
dans l'alcool la DA je veux écrire pour
être avec les autres disons que
l'écriture m'a sauvé de beaucoup de
choses pas le métier d'acteur cette
colère donc que vous avez en vous parce
que finalement c'est une espèce de
colère de révolte cet excès cette soif
en même temps d'amour et cetera d'après
vous ça vient vraiment de votre enfance
roman dit le problème de naissance mon
père est marqué par ça ou ouais ou ouais
certain enfin je sais pas si je crois
qu'on est avec déjà une somme de
d'ingrédients qui vont faire ce qu'on va
être dans le futur j'ai jamais été
enfant moi
donc je suis passé direct au combat moi
alors donc pas d'enfance non non pas
aucune enfance aucune enfance rien rien
rien rien pourri qu'est-ce que vous
imaginiez vous étant enfant qu'est-ce
qu'on vous disait pendant la guerre mais
ça c'est pas mon problème ça jamais été
mon
problème allementand non non ça jamais
été mon problème c'était un problème
pour les autres surtout parce que moi
j'étais le fils de Bosch pendant des
années ta mère c'est une salob pendant
des années après comme j'avais un
physique méditerranéen disons j'ai étais
à l'époque antisémite j'étais le
saluppin et puis après quand ça a été
les Arabes les Algériens oh put
j'avais tes frères là voilà
j'entendais voilà donc petit à petit
j'ai construit une certitude en
moi laquelle je serai tout ça contre
vous s'il le faut
ça contre vous s'il le faut je serai je
serai le fils du je serai le fils
du Juif je serai je serai mais je serai
un humain plein d'amour plein de plein
de de volonté de é sur la culture des
autres sur je suis resté en fin de
compte je suis resté tout ça je l'ai
tellement imprimé dans ma tête que je
suis resté à la fois le fils du Bos à la
fois le fils du juif et à la fois le
fils de l'arabe et j'en suis très fier
est-ce que vous avez
recherché vos parents non je suis pas
très fier de ça pourquoi parce que
j'aurais dû être plus grand que ça pas
les laisser mourir tout seul comme ça
j'aurais dû être plus grand que ça
j'aurais dû dire mais quoi quel jugement
à la con je dis aussi si je peux faire
passer un truc pour des jeunes gens qui
seraient très révoltés contre leur et
ils vivent en Allemagne de toute façon
il sont partis donc votre mère est
partie avec cette officialement en
Allemagne reg je regrette de pas les
avoir accompagné plus quoi dans leur
vieillesse vous les avez vu combien de
fois dans votre vie je sais pas une
dizaine de fois oui une dizaine de fois
mais qu'est-ce que vous auriez voulu
faire allz les retrouver oui oui
exactement les accompagner dans leur
vieillesse et et pas les laisser tout
seul comme ça quoi voilà sentiment
d'avoir manqué ça ah oui non mais oui en
même temps ils ont manqué aussi votre ou
mais oui mais l'enfance en oui mais peu
importe ça quand on arrive à plus de 50
ans on doit
poser tout ça on doit le poser on doit
le poser pour donner la main et aller
voir sa vieille mère et lui dire allez
va qu'est-ce que vous lui auriez dit je
ne sais pas mais je lui aurais dit tout
va bien l'important c'était de lui dire
ça l'important c'était de le vivre avec
voilà c'est tout et à votre père pareil
euh oui oui bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr
mon père pareil bien sûr bien sûr bien
sûr non non mais mon père il y a pas de
problème non
plus et puis maintenant bah c'est un
grand un grand chagrin pour moi de pas
l'avoir fait quoi chagrin parce que je
trouve pas ça bien c'est tout quand vous
étiez gamin dans cette cité avec votre
grand-mère seul vous penseiez à quoi
vous savez c'est comme un peu comme les
acteurs quand on les
interview ils avaient tous la vocation
et et alors donc ils avaient un grenier
il se déguisaient quand ils étaient
petits quoi
c'est pas mon histoire ça moi je suis
devenu acteur pour le pognon et puis
c'est après
que que je me suis rendu compte qu'on
pouvait être acteur pour autre chose que
le poignon qu' avait autre chose qui
était magnifique làdedans et tout mais
au départ tout me faisait peur tout dans
ce métier d'abord j'étais quelqu'un
d'extrêmement timide donc vous êtes
toujours timide ouais très timide
mais vous
savez j'ai eu des personnes qui m'ont
vachement aimé et vachement aidé et
toute façon je dis encore aujourd'hui
merci au cinéma j'ai pas dans ma
solitude par rapport au cinéma j'oublie
pas de dire merci et est-ce que vous
avez eu des paires de substitution
est-ce que vous en êtes créé ou des mes
de sub non mais Michel aucller c'était
mon père adoptif j'ai des frères
adoptifs non non la mère non on remplace
pas la mère et la grand-mère votre
grand-mère oui Non Non mais une
grand-mère remplace pas la mère non non
je suis pas d'accord pas pour moi en
toutous les cas non c'est une question
donc c'est la grande absente la mère oui
c'est la grande absente mais maintenant
elle est très présente en moi et
et c'est bien ça la merde c'est que j'y
pense tous les jours quoi mais bon ça
aussi on va finir par le mettre dans un
petit paquet et
puis mettre dans la colonne de de ce
qu'on a pas fait quoi mais c'est pas il
faut pas s'arrêter à ça non plus il faut
continuer les choses quel père vous êtes
moi je vous qui n'avez pas de modèle de
père justement quel père vous êtes ouais
moi je suis un père qui parle voilà
c'est tout alors je parle dans la
cuisine et puis ceux qui veulent bien
entendre ils entendent h je suis pas un
père directif je suis pas un
[Musique]
père je suis pas un père laxiste non
plus mais
euh j'ai pas d'autorité non plus j'ai
aucune autorité parce que c'est vrai
qu'elle n'a pas eu non plus une enfance
facile roman dans le fond non avec la
disparition de sa mère très je elle a
toujours eu elle a toujours eu de
l'amour quand même he sacré caractère
aussi bah c'est une chinoise hein c'est
une asiate i sa maman était oui mais
elle aussi elle est carér chinoise ou
oui vietnamien vietnamienne j'ai
toujours fait dans le melting
pot c'est pas je suis pas un gars bien
raisonnable avec ça et évident aussi de
de le de faire jouer roman ah ben ça de
toute façon tant que tant que j'existe
tant qu'elle existera et tant que je
ferai des choses si je peux retravailler
avec elle je travaill avec elle non mais
là c'était particulier parce que c'est
une autobiographie elle joue votre fille
dans le vous savez on a même tourné la
scène que vous voyez là la photo que
vous voyez là le bistro que j'avais
recréé il est à 20 m de l'endroit où sa
maman est morte voilà
c'est c'est chargé ah non mais nous on
est chargé nous la famille Bagé on est
très chargé ce que je me suis demandé
c'est que le fait justement d'avoir
roman à cette époque puisquil y avait un
enfant ça ne vous a pas donné envie
d'arrêter justement l'Alco l'alcool non
mais non non non non non non vous auriez
plus dire pour elle non non j'arrête
vous êtes senti en danger non jamais je
sais pas jamais si je me suis senti en
danger tous les jours de ma vie mais il
y a des dangers qu'on avec lesquels on
on peut qu'on peut affronter et faire
face et puis il y en a d'autres qui sont
plus nosé à bon évidemment et qui vous
abîment bien plus quoi en général quand
on veut s'en sortir c'est un tout petit
peu tard ça veut dire par là jamais rien
n'est trop tard mais on y a déjà laissé
des plumes donc la convalessence c'est
plus longue mais moi ce que je veux
savoir c'est comment justement vous en
êtes sorti qu'est-ce qu'il fait
abandonné vous avez dit stop ah mais non
mais il y a un moment où c'est ce que je
dis à 20 ans on veut mourir à 60 on veut
rester hein vous avez arrêté avant 60
oui oui bien sûr mais mais c'est un peu
ce qui s'est passé aussi hein euh et a
part ce moment vous arrêtez
fastoch quand
vous quand vous commencez dans ce machin
là vous pensez c'est parce que vous
aimez pas la
vie voulez la fuir que voulez la tuer et
puis brusquement si vous prenez
conscience que vous l'aimez follement
cette de vie mais que pour la viv
C de vie il va falloir arrêter ça
parce que ça s la vi pas vous
arrêtez question d'amour avec la vie
donc avec soi vous ça vous est arrivé je
crois parce que vous avez fait des vrais
commat non
j'en ai fait deux moi des d' et tout
comment on dit des comas et les TBI
m'expliquent au service de réanimation
m'expliquz vous en voulez et c'est là
d'où est partie toute ma théorie en fin
de compte c'est d'abord que j'avais eu
un tout bib il m'avais dit mais moi je
te fous en clinique je vais te calmer la
douleur mais tu vas recommencer en
sortant tant que tu as pas réglé
toi-même le truc je peux rien faire pour
toi ce qu'il a dit oui et c'était vrai
si la décision elle vient pas de
quelqu'un d'autre elle vient de soir
puis j'ai eu un flic aussi dans ma vie
j'ai eu un
flic je suis unli que je me suis fait
serrer comme on dit un jour bien sûr
qu'est-ce qu'il vous a dit j'ai senti
une sourde colère en
lui il a
commencé mais Mo je sais ce que tu fais
tu écris des pièces de
théâtre tu écris des pièces de théâtre
et tout mais tu crois quoi tu CIS tu
veux que je te fasse voir des photos moi
de M qui sont morts avec la cam tu veux
que je te fasse voir et puis il montait
il montait puis d'un seul coup il a dit
mais c'est moi qui devrais me camer je
suis dans la merde toute la journée
toutes les nuits je vois des meurs des
gens malheureux des machins des trucs
c'est moi qui devrais en prendre pas toi
B je sais que tu vas pas me
balancer le mec alors casse-toi
casse-toi je veux plus te voir
simplement la prochaine fois si je te
vois dans cet ét là je te sers et je te
garde je suis sorti je me souviens j'ai
traversé le pont et je suis resté
attaché à l'image de ce flic
ouais je suis resté attaché je lui dois
un bout de ma vie quoi je lu dois un
bout de ma compréhension du truc quoi
parce qu'il a fait un texte incroyable
de douleur incroyable cet homme monsieur
Quintard il prenait sa retraite 2 ans
après je crois et puis c'est pas tout de
suite parce que j'ai recommencé tout de
suite c'est un mois après que j'ai pris
la décision mais en fin de compte sur le
son encore sur l'écho des mots Quintard
et puis et puis voilà et puis après j'ai
arrêté et puis et puis ça fait quoi j'ai
arrêté depuis 1967 et il y a même pas eu
l'envie quoi et c'est comme ça que vous
vous êtes retrouvé avec donc cette
hépatite grave oui le résultat de la de
la cam quoi ça a été quand même quelques
années plus tard la découverte qu'
m'avait filé une maladie très grave oui
parce que vous m'avez dit en venant ici
je veux parler de quelque chose
d'important ouis parce que je veux
parler de l'hépathtite C de parce que il
y a beaucoup beaucoup de gens qui sont
touché en France on d'après les sondages
il y a 500000 un truc comme ça moi je
crois qu'il y en a un peu plus pourquoi
vous dites ça parce que ben parce qu'il
y a beaucoup de gens qui se planquent
qui ont peur de tout ça et qui se
planquent et qui se mettent pas en face
croyez que les gens justement ont peur
ont peur du traitement ont peur de
parler de de cette maladie oui ils ont
peur de parler de cette maladie paatites
les patites C en
particulier bah oui c'est celle qui a la
plus mauvaise réputation puis toi vous
saz que certains médecins sont pas
toujours très
adroits moi il y en a un un jour il me
dit il n'en parleit pas parce que
vous savez c'est comme le sida ça tout
le monde en a peur donc vous fermez la
porte de
vous-même oui oui oui oui oui oui bien
sûr il y a un médecin qui m'a dit ça
mais les médecins disent plein de trucs
il croient qu'on lui dira jamais mais
ils disent plein de trucs et puis il y a
des super médecins aussi ça il faut le
dire parce que
est-ce que vous faites ce qu'il faut et
vous laiss ah bah moi je l'ai fait mais
j'ai mis c'est pour ça que je peux en
parler j'ai mis beaucoup de temps à le
faire donc c'estàdire vous saviez que
vous étiez malade et vous ne vous êtes
pas soigné le SO vous êtes en train de
dire ouais ouais pendant une dizaine
pendant oui pendant une dizaine d'années
ouais alors là aussi il y a eu des
années de colère et ainsi de suite mais
parce que je le savais pas je savais pas
que cette que le foie provoquait
des carrément comme des tumeurs au
cerveau quoi ça veut dire si vous êtes
un peu caractériel vous allez être
immensément caractériel si vous êtes un
peu coléreux vous allez être immensément
et ainsi de suite et tout donc vous
retrouvez mais misérable comme un humain
avec des
excroissances mais qui sont plus du tout
les les vôtres mais comme les autres
savent que vous êtes Ron bah alors ça
dit B il a encore plus rçon puis vous
vous savez pas que ça ça vous ça
accélère ça et tout donc sil y a un état
de solitude c'est vrai assez grand et je
le dis aussi euh pour tous les gens que
j'ai pu blesser dans ces excès quoi dans
ces pardonnez-moi parce que je je il
était grand temps que je me soigne quoi
voilà il était grand temps mais il a
quelque chose de un peu plus apaisé
c'est pas en vous c'est peut-être parce
qu'il faut que je m'économise en ce
moment c'est peut-être pour ça c'est
peut-être pour ça oui oui il faut que je
fasse un peu attention ouais oui mais un
peu attention j'entends par là de pas
réveiller les souffrances quoi je je me
mets à l'abri de
de
moi-même pour ne rien manquer sur ma
chaîne Ina mire Guma abonnez-vous et
activez la
[Musique]
cloche